>> SALLY: Hallo!
Herzlich willkommen zu Sallys Welt!
Ich habe es euch schon lange versprochen,
heute gibt es das Küchenorganisationsvideo.
Und warum eine Küche überhaupt organisiert sein soll,
hat wirklich ganz viele Gründe.
Zum einen habt ihr dann kurze Arbeits- und Laufwege,
ihr habt eine Zeitersparnis
und vor allem findet ihr immer alles gleich,
zumindest, wenn sie super organisiert ist.
Ich habe jetzt hier einige Tipps und Tricks
für euch zusammengesucht.
Ich habe ja diese Küche hier schon seit über zwei Jahren.
Und ich habe sie damals auch so eingerichtet,
dass ich gesagt habe, so ist es für mich am logischsten.
Aber natürlich merkt man mit der Zeit,
vor allem innerhalb von zwei Jahren,
okay, vielleicht sind die Laufwege doch ein bisschen zu groß,
vielleicht brauche ich das eine mehr, das andere weniger.
Und deswegen wird jetzt heute hier
die Küche noch mal optimiert und organisiert.
Und die ganzen Tipps und Tricks,
die ich jetzt zusammensuche, gebe ich an euch weiter.
[Musik]
Oftmals ist es ja auch so,
dass in den teuersten und stylisten Küchen
eigentlich fast nie gekocht wird,
weil die meisten wirklich eher Wert aufs Äußere legen
statt aufs Innere.
Aber mir war es zum Beispiel schon immer wichtig,
dass meine Küche funktional und praktisch ist.
Natürlich soll sie auch gut aussehen,
aber das war bei mir eigentlich eher immer zweitrangig.
Die Küche ist bei mir nämlich mein Arbeitsplatz.
Ich lebe hier, ich wohne hier,
aber, wie gesagt, am meisten arbeite ich eben auch am Herd.
Und was ich noch viel lieber mache,
als in der Küche zu stehen und zu werkeln,
ist natürlich, Zeit mit meinen Kindern zu verbringen
und Zeit auch woanders zu verbringen.
Das heißt, die Küche muss top organisiert sein.
Und entweder könnt ihr jetzt hergehen
und direkt bei eurer Küchenplanung praktisch darauf achten
oder ihr könnt auch eure bestehende Küche
wirklich organisieren und optimieren.
Und ich zeige euch wie.
Die Küche kann man nämlich
in verschiedene Küchenzonen einteilen,
nämlich das Lagern der Lebensmittel, also die Bevorratung,
das Vorbereiten der Lebensmittel,
Spülen und Müll,
die Koch- und Backzone,
das Aufbewahren von diversen Gegenständen
und dann noch das Anrichten, das heißt Geschirr und Besteck.
Was dabei auch ganz wichtig ist,
dass ihr in eurer Küche wirklich nur das verstaut,
was ihr auch braucht.
Das heißt, trennt euch ruhig auch mal von alten Dingen.
So habe ich es auch bei meinem Kleiderschrankausmisten
schon gezeigt.
Schaut wirklich: Was benutzt ihr? Was benutzt ihr nicht?
Oft hängt man auch an Dingen,
die man wirklich gar nicht braucht.
Und vielleicht freut sich ja jemand anderes darüber.
Wovon ich ehrlich gesagt nicht so viel halte,
ist, wenn ihr jetzt wirklich den kompletten Kücheninhalt
einmal auspackt auf die Arbeitsfläche.
Denn dann habt ihr das Problem,
dass ihr vielleicht nicht am gleichen Tag fertig werdet.
Und wenn ihr alles draußen stehen habt,
geht also meiner Meinung nach
die Motivation ein bisschen flöten.
Und deswegen nehmt euch wirklich
immer nur Bereich für Bereich vor,
mistet sofort aus,
überlegt euch: Brauche ich es oder brauche ich es nicht?
Und so Geräte wie zum Beispiel ein Raclette-Grill,
was auch wir nur einmal im Jahr benutzen oder zweimal,
so was muss ich nicht in der Küche lagern.
Das kann ich auch im Keller lagern, wenn ich einen habe,
oder im Vorratsraum oder in dem anderen Raum
oder ganz weit oben, wo ich es eben nicht brauche.
Und deswegen, würde ich jetzt sagen,
mache ich jetzt mal alle Schubladen und Schränke auf
und fange an auszumisten, auszuräumen.
Und ich gucke mal, ob ich heute fertig werde
oder doch erst morgen.
Ich fange jetzt bei mir hier im Spülbereich an.
Und der Spülbereich ist eigentlich so ein zentraler Platz
bei uns in der Küche.
Nämlich, er ist direkt hinter dem Vorbereitungsbereich
und neben dem Kochbereich.
Und der Spülbereich sollte halt auch
schon gut ausgestattet und organisiert sein.
Und was mir hier die letzten Wochen und Monate
aufgefallen ist:
Ich habe das ganz gut organisiert.
Also ich habe es auch so, dass
– und das ist eigentlich die beste Aufteilung.
Wenn ihr Platz habt, macht es auch gern so.
Ich habe hier das Spülbecken in der Mitte,
rechts davon der Mülleimer
und links davon ist die Spülmaschine.
Das heißt nämlich, wenn ich hier am Spülbecken stehe
und unser Geschirr vom Tisch wegräume
und dann habe ich vielleicht noch ein paar Essensreste,
– keine Ahnung –
Olivenkerne mit drin,
dann kann ich die hier direkt in den Mülleimer geben
und hier links dann eben einräumen.
Und dann passiert eben nicht Folgendes,
wenn hier jemand steht und spült,
dass man ständig hier aufmacht
und den Müll noch wegräumen muss.
Was mir nur aufgefallen ist:
Ich habe zwar hier alles gut organisiert,
aber dadurch, dass ich nichts beschriftet habe,
passiert es dann schon oft,
dass mir entweder was fehlt,
weil außer mir dann zum Beispiel keiner weiß,
was ich hier gerne habe,
oder dass was dabeisteht, was ich hier gar nicht brauche.
Das heißt, ich räume jetzt hier kurz alles aus
und fange an zu beschriften.
Denn dann kann ich wieder
die Ordnung herstellen, die ich immer haben möchte,
und muss dann weniger aufräumen und hinterherräumen.
[Musik]
Guckt mal. Wenn ich dann ausgeräumt und aufgeräumt habe,
kommt so was zustande.
Das heißt, es sammelt sich doch mal gerne
was in Schubladen, was da eben nicht hingehört.
Das heißt, das hier ist jetzt ausgemistet.
Das hat einen anderen Platz hier im Haus.
Und ich habe jetzt alles so aufgeräumt,
wie ich es hier auch brauche.
Das heißt, alles, was ich zum Spülen brauche, ist hier verstaut:
Spülbürsten, Spülschwämme, Handschuhe,
aber auch die Reiniger.
Die einzigen Reinigungsmittel, muss ich sagen,
die ich jetzt hier wegstelle,
das sind diese Tabs zum Reinigen der Kaffeemaschine.
Denn ich finde, die sehen aus wie Hustenbonbons.
Es ist zwar mit einem Gefahrensymbol gekennzeichnet,
aber man muss auch hier sagen,
hier sind wir ja gerade in unserem Studiobereich sozusagen.
Die Kinder dürfen hier nicht alleine her.
Tiere haben wir auch keine.
Deswegen habe ich die Reiniger
und die Utensilien hier unten mit drin.
Aber, wenn ihr zu Hause Kinder habt oder kleine
– kleine Kinder oder Tiere, wollte ich sagen,
dann verstaut die Reiniger auf jeden Fall weiter oben,
wo eben keiner drankommt.
Und genau, die Reiniger-Tabs mache ich jetzt hier weg.
Die kommen zur Kaffeemaschine.
Die waren auch gar nicht hier, wollte ich euch nur zeigen.
Und alles andere werde ich jetzt so etikettieren,
dass auch, wenn zum Beispiel Spülmittel leer ist,
da noch Spülmittel dransteht
und dann jeder weiß,
okay, da muss ein Spülmittel nachgekauft werden.
Und ich hatte euch ja immer mal wieder
meine Etikettiergeräte auch gezeigt.
Und ich hatte normalerweise immer so ein Etikettiergerät,
wo ich es praktisch am Gerät eintippe, ausdrucke,
was auch ganz praktisch ist.
Aber, wenn ich mehrere Bereiche im Haus etikettiere,
habe ich dann immer das Problem,
dass ich mit der Größe der Schrift
oder auch mit der Schriftfarbe und so weiter
Probleme bekam.
Und jetzt habe ich mir hier von Brother
diesen P-touch Cube zugelegt.
Und zwar gibt es da eine App dazu
und ich muss dann nicht am Gerät eintippen,
sondern kann wirklich in der App
– da gibt es schon Etiketten, die so vorgefertigt sind,
also vorgefertigte Designs.
Oder ich kann sagen, ich mache ein ganz eigenes Etikett.
Und ich habe einfach verschiedenfarbige Banderolen,
habe dann verschiedene Bereiche,
kann verschiedenfarbig drucken
und kann jetzt hier auch meinen eigenen Text
mit Symbolen eingeben,
wie hier jetzt zum Beispiel
"Spülbürsten",
und kann dann meine eingestellten Schriftgrößen,
die Farbe, die Form, die Textart, die Schriftart,
Symbole oder Bilder auch speichern
und dann beim nächsten Mal,
wenn ich eben wieder was drucken möchte in dem Bereich,
einfach ausdrucken.
Und das ist halt einfacher,
als das jedes Mal immer wieder händisch auszuprobieren.
Und hier nehme ich jetzt
eine gelbe Banderole.
Spülen gelb so ein bisschen auch als Gefahrenhinweis.
[Musik]
Und hier bei der Zitronensäure mache ich es jetzt so:
Ich habe nämlich auch immer Zitronensäure da,
von oben erkennt man die Verpackung allerdings nicht.
Deswegen drucke ich jetzt jedes Etikett zweimal.
Ich kann also hier einfach antippen,
wie oft ich das Etikett brauche,
drücke hier zweimal.
Dann kann ich nämlich das Gefäß an sich
und den Boden beschriften.
[Musik]
Ich kann auch theoretisch nach jedem Etikett
immer hier die Schneidetaste benutzen.
Aber ich spare einfach dieses Bändchen,
wenn ich alles am Stück ausdrucke.
Und hier habe ich ja so eine Markierung in der Mitte...
Ups.
Und hier habe ich ja so eine Markierung in der Mitte
und da kann ich jetzt mit der Schere was wegschneiden,
ohne dass ich eben Abfall habe.
Also das ist schon ganz gut.
Wenn man direkt weiß, man will mehrere Sachen drucken,
nutzt man einfach die Option, um Müll zu sparen.
[Musik]
Während des Aufräumens fällt mir jetzt gerade auf,
dass ich euch die Küchenbereiche
noch gar nicht gezeigt habe.
Also ich stehe jetzt hier am Kochbereich,
im Prinzip an meinem Herd.
Hier muss ich alles und möchte auch alles verstauen,
was ich zum Kochen brauche,
das heißt Töpfe und Pfannen, Kochgeschirr,
Küchenwerkzeug,
aber genauso gut Öl, Gewürze,
alles, was hier praktisch um den Kochtopf herum passiert.
Hinter mir habe ich ja meine Backöfen.
Das ist auch sozusagen der Backbereich.
Deswegen auch dort Backformen.
Aber, wenn ich jetzt Torten zum Beispiel vorbereite,
Teige rühre, knete, Cremes schlage,
mache ich das entweder meist hier, wenn die Kamera läuft,
oder wenn die Kamera nicht läuft, muss ich sagen,
lasse ich die Küchenmaschinen nämlich dahinten stehen,
da, wo sie sind.
Denn gerade dort habe ich dann
so den Backbereich bei der Kenwood
oder eben auch bei der KitchenAid stehen.
Dort habe ich die Küchenmaschinenzubehörteile.
Und deswegen sind die auch direkt darunter.
Ich habe dann
– das habe ich euch ja schon gezeigt –
hier den Spülbereich.
Das heißt, alles, was an Geschirr anfällt, wird hier gespült,
wie gesagt, auch die Spülmaschine
und die Mülleimer.
Dann habe ich hier den Vorbereitungsbereich.
Und der Vorbereitungsbereich ist sozusagen
das Herzstück der Küche.
Denn da steht man am meisten.
Alles, was an Gemüse, Fleisch, Lebensmitteln zubereitet wird,
das heißt, auf Schneidebrettern geschnitten wird,
ausgerollt, ausgewählt wird,
passiert hier.
Also muss ich hier dann auch in der Nähe
meine Messer aufbewahren,
aber genauso gut meine Schneidebretter aufbewahren
und alles hier auch an kleinen Küchen-Gadgets
wie zum Beispiel Sparschälern,
kleinen Messern oder auch Hobel,
also Küchenhobel und kleine Geräte hier griffbereit haben.
Deswegen zieht zum Beispiel auch mein Messerblock um,
der eigentlich da drüben immer stand.
Den werde ich dann hier platzieren.
Dann habe ich da bei den Schränken
meine Vorräte,
also meine Lebensmittelvorräte.
Und hier habe ich jetzt, weil ich viele Backvorräte habe,
eben einen Backschrank
und daneben dran die anderen Schränke
mit weiteren Zubehörsachen.
Dann habe ich den Bereich Anrichten,
das heißt alles, was auf den Tisch kommt
an Geschirr und Besteck.
Das haben wir auch momentan nicht so ganz optimal.
Denn wir haben hier sozusagen unser Geschirr drin,
was dann mit zum Tisch genommen wird,
und am Ende der Küche das Besteck.
Das muss ich jetzt auch ein bisschen umorganisieren.
Das ist wirklich da drüben am Fenster.
Das hatte irgendwie platztechnische Gründe.
Also es ging irgendwie nicht anders.
Aber ich werde es jetzt umorganisieren.
Man muss da im Prinzip überlegen,
jetzt gerade bei Geschirr,
wir sind zum Beispiel eine vierköpfige Familie
und bei uns decken ja Samira und Ela den Tisch mit.
Hier jetzt im Bereich nicht, aber eher bei uns drüben.
Und da müssen die sozusagen ans Besteck drankommen,
an die Geschirrsachen drankommen.
Und da gucke ich dann schon,
dass der Weg von Geschirr zum Esstisch nicht so weit ist.
Aber, wenn ich jetzt zum Beispiel an Josh denke
oder an andere junge Menschen, die einfach zu Hause sind,
es muss schnell und pragmatisch und praktisch sein,
dann würde ich das Geschirr
in der Nähe der Spülmaschine aufbewahren,
damit man wirklich einfach nur beim Kochen
sich was drauf schöpfen kann, essen kann
und dann später das Geschirr in die Spülmaschine räumt
und nach der Spülmaschine direkt ohne lange Laufwege
wieder in den Schrank zurück verräumt.
Also so muss man halt ein bisschen mitdenken.
Und dann gibt es noch den Aufbewahrungsbereich.
Das heißt, alles, was noch anfällt
an zum Beispiel Vorratsgläsern, Vorratsbehältern,
habe ich jetzt momentan, muss ich sagen,
hier unten,
da drüben und da vorne,
also so ein bisschen verteilt.
Und eigentlich mache ich jetzt
das, was ich nicht so häufig brauche,
eher nach hinten an die Küche,
wo ich nicht so gut drankomme,
und Dinge, die ich häufiger für den Kühlschrank brauche,
dahinten, wo ich dann auch
den Kühlschrank in der Nähe habe.
Ja. Deswegen muss jetzt hier ordentlich umgeräumt werden
und zwar so richtig.
Hier habe ich zum Beispiel am Vorbereitungsbereich
– nee, noch mal.
Hier habe ich zum Beispiel im Vorbereitungs-
>> MURAT: Ich muss die Kinder abholen, ja?
>> SALLY: Ja.
Reg dich bitte nicht über mich auf.
Ich räume die Küche um.
>> MURAT: Hm.
>> SALLY: Es wird nicht mehr so, wie es war, aber
aber ich sage dir eines:
Du kannst nicht über mich schimpfen.
Denn ich werde jetzt alles beschriften.
>> MURAT: Ja.
Ich glaube das erst, wenn die Tinte getrocknet ist.
Hm.
Ich weiß ganz genau, dass du jede Woche rumräumst.
>> MURAT: Weil sonst wüsste ich ja, wo alles hingehört.
>> SALLY: Gar nicht!
>> SALLY: Komm, ich zeige dir was.
>> MURAT: Was?
>> SALLY: Komm.
Komm.
Wenn du das nächste...
>> MURAT: Kann der Mülleimer wenigstens dort bleiben,
wo er ist?
>> SALLY: Ja, der bleibt.
Wenn du das nächste Mal Spülmittel zum Beispiel leer machst
>> MURAT: Ja.
>> SALLY: und ich sehe hier "Spülmittel",
weiß ich ganz genau, dass du es leer gemacht hast
und kein frisches reingestellt hast.
>> MURAT: Hm.
>> SALLY: Weil ich habe es druntergeschrieben.
Siehst du das?
>> MURAT: Weißt du, auf was ich warte?
>> SALLY: Hm?
>> MURAT: Dass du uns auch etikettierst.
Zum Beispiel "Kind 1", "Kind 2",
"Ehemann".
>> SALLY: Ehemann 1 und 2 gibt es nicht.
Es gibt ja nur einen.
>> MURAT: Nein, "Kind 1", "Kind 2", "Ehemann".
Ich hole jetzt die Kinder ab, okay?
>> SALLY: Nein, nur Kind 2 bitte, nur Ela.
>> MURAT: Ja, Kind 2.
>> SALLY: Kind 1 schläft heute bei Oma.
>> MURAT: Ja.
>> SALLY: Kriegst du das hin?
Hier habe ich zum Beispiel im Vorbereitungsbereich
Vorratsdosen,
also diese ganzen Glasvorratsdosen mit Deckel,
die ich hier eigentlich nicht brauche.
Denn hier bräuchte ich jetzt eher
alles, was ich hier zum Zubereiten brauche,
zum Beispiel meine Schüsseln,
meine Messbecher.
Deswegen räume ich hier jetzt alles da rüber
und von da alles da rüber,
damit der Murat nicht mehr suchen muss.
[Musik]
Also alles zum Thema Vorbereiten
kommt jetzt aus der Schublade in diese.
Und ich habe mir lange Gedanken darüber gemacht,
wie ich das mit den Einteilern mache.
Denn ich hatte bisher immer nur so feste Einteiler,
die zum Beispiel auch magnetisch waren,
die auch ganz praktisch sind.
Aber es gibt halt dann doch Dinge
wie zum Beispiel diese Deckel
oder die Kochblume oder meine Faltsiebe,
die haben einfach alle eine unterschiedliche Größe
und dann fallen sie um,
dann muss man sie irgendwo einquetschen.
Und ich habe jetzt mal, um das Chaos zu beseitigen,
den SpaceFlexx bestellt.
Und zwar ist der geeignet für alle Schubladen
ab 60 cm Frontbreite.
Also der passt wirklich in jede gängige Haushaltsschublade.
Und den kann man dann individuell einstellen.
Ich habe den jetzt schon zusammengebaut.
Ich zeige es euch gleich, wie einfach das geht.
Und den setze ich jetzt mal hier rein.
Perfect!
Ich glaube, da passt vielleicht noch ein zweiter dazu.
Und da kann ich jetzt mal alles einrichten.
[Musik]
Uh!
Ohne Fingerabdrücke.
Ha ja.
Wenn ich schon umräume,
dann kann ich es nicht mit Fingerabdrücken einräumen.
Das geht nicht.
Man munkelt, sie hat Spaß daran, ihre Küche zu organisieren.
[Musik]
Wenn dann die beiden Seiten fertig sind,
kommen jetzt noch hier diese Stangen dran.
Und die sind zwar fest, also die haben eine Länge,
aber man kann das Ganze trotzdem einstellen.
Nämlich, man kann entweder hier oben
die Stange hineinstecken
und sozusagen die Breite länger lassen
oder man kann eins tiefer gehen
und sozusagen die Stange etwas tiefer reinfahren lassen
und dann wird das Ganze etwas schmaler.
Also das war jetzt ziemlich einfach.
Und jetzt kommen hier diese flexiblen Innenteile rein.
Und die einfach nur noch hier rein.
Und fertig.
So. Das ist jetzt mein erster SpaceFlexx,
den ich zusammengebaut habe.
Und beim ersten ist es schon ein bisschen knifflig,
aber man muss sagen,
wenn man einmal das System verstanden hat
und sich an die Anleitung hält,
dann geht es.
Man muss halt die Anleitung lesen.
Aber nach dem zweiten, finde ich,
weiß man, wie es zusammengehört,
und dann ist es perfekt.
Und bei diesem SpaceFlexx hier ist es so,
der ist jetzt etwas kleiner als der, den ich da unten drin habe.
Und das ist entweder für eine schmale Schublade,
die zum Beispiel
so etwas schmaler ist.
Dann hat man so die Einteilung.
Oder ihr könnt sagen, ihr habt eine Schublade,
die nicht so tief geht.
Das habe ich oft an der Kücheninsel auf der Rückseite,
weil da zum Beispiel der Herd ist
oder noch die Lüftung.
Und dann hat man Schubladen, die nicht so tief reingehen.
Und dann kann man es auch quer benutzen.
Also da gibt es verschiedene Größen.
Guten Morgen!
Ich habe heute Nacht
– ich hatte einen Traum vom Schubladenorganisieren.
Und mir kam im Traum die Idee,
dass meine Zuschauer, also ihr
mir Bilder schickt von euren Schubladen, Schränken,
unaufgeräumten Küchen
und ich finde eine Lösung dazu.
Dazu komme ich später.
Denn ich sammle die jetzt gerade noch.
Was ich jetzt hier mache:
Bevor ich jetzt hier
– ich habe schon meinen Plan im Kopf.
Aber, bevor ihr jetzt planlos eure Schubladen ausräumt,
umräumen und so weiter,
macht euch doch vorher einen Plan.
Zeichnet eure Küchenzonen ein,
zeichnet eure Schränke ein
und schreibt ungefähr hin, was ihr wo verstauen wollt.
Dann geht es nämlich einfacher.
So mache ich das jetzt.
[Musik]
Ihr erkennt wahrscheinlich gar nichts.
Also...
Der Marcel, der macht das jetzt für euch einmal digital.
Und zwar
habe ich in der Mitte meine Kochinsel.
Und auf der Kochinsel auf der Seite
habe ich ja die Vorbereitungen,
also wo ich immer schneide, schnibble und so weiter.
Da müssen praktisch alle Werkzeuge rein.
Die Kochzone ist ja klar.
Da kommen Töpfe, Gewürze, Öl, Kochbesteck hin,
auch vor und hinter der Insel.
Ich laufe ja da so immer dazwischen.
Hier hinten bei der KitchenAid werde ich jetzt auch in Zukunft
mein KitchenAid-Zubehör lagern, was ich häufig brauche.
So Sachen, die ich selten brauche,
wie zum Beispiel Nudelwalze, nicht,
weil das einfach unnötig wäre
dort direkt in der Zone.
Spülen haben wir fertig.
Kenwood habe ich ja auch immer dort stehen
und arbeite auch dort mit der Kenwood.
Dort mache ich auch das Zubehör hin, was ich häufig brauche.
Und rechts, wo Platz ist, mache ich Aufbewahren hin,
damit ich auch den Weg zum Kühlschrank immer habe
für Lebensmittelreste.
Auf der Insel von hier vorne gesehen dann
links von der Kochzone habe ich noch mal Kochen,
weil das ist ja alles so da mit drin.
Das ist ja praktisch der Herd, Kochen.
Dann habe ich da noch eine Spüle
und auch Aufbewahren, was ich seltener brauche.
Dort werde ich auch die Handtücher verstauen.
Und dann hinten die Schränke,
da habe ich Backschrank,
dann dieser Kaffeemaschinenschrank,
dann wieder Backschrank,
der ja unten voll ist mit so Backzubehör.
Dann habe ich meine Vorräte,
Vorrat und Geschirr.
Und das muss ich vielleicht umräumen
nach vorne an die Insel.
Denn direkt an der Insel hier,
also hier dran ist ja bei uns der Essbereich.
Und deswegen muss ich mein Geschirr umräumen,
weil wir immer Geschirr und Besteck relativ häufig brauchen
und das hier an den Tisch muss.
Und deshalb werde ich hier Geschirr und Besteck
und Sachen aufbewahren, die ich seltener brauche.
Ja, auf der Rückseite der Insel.
So machen wir es jetzt.
Josh, hast du schon Angst?
>> JOSH: Ein bisschen, ja.
>> SALLY: Brauchst du nicht. Ich habe einen Plan.
Es war schon logisch, die Dinge,
die ich praktisch zum Vorbereiten meiner Lebensmittel,
also zum Beispiel hier so einen Multizerkleinerer
oder hier den Spirelli
– es ist schon logisch, dass hier aufzubewahren,
weil ich es ja immer hier brauche.
Aber es gibt ja Dinge, die brauche ich oft,
und es gibt Dinge, die brauche ich selten,
zum Beispiel einen Ananasschneider.
Einen Ananasschneider brauche ich jetzt nicht täglich
und auch nicht wöchentlich.
Das heißt, der kann jetzt hier weg,
nach hinten
zu dem Zeug, was ich eben nicht so oft brauche.
Aber so was wie hier
mein Zerkleinerer, den ich echt oft im Einsatz habe,
der kommt jetzt hier zur Insel.
Und dann habe ich hier nämlich Platz
für die KitchenAid-Zubehörteile.
Dann weiß auch jeder, hier steht die KitchenAid
und die steht halt eben immer hier.
Dann habe ich hier drunter das Zubehör.
Haha!
[Musik]
Wow! Wie viele Siebe habe ich eigentlich?
800?
Aber ich kann dir eines sagen:
Die kamen von drüben.
Denn ich brauche hier nur eins.
Das ist halt von meinem...
Und das.
Und
das.
Die kommen rüber.
Die waren in der anderen Küche.
Vier sind okay.
Vier sind okay, Josh.
[Musik]
Josh, ich organisiere das hier wieder zurück nach links.
Da, wo es hingehört!
Denn diese Abroller für Frischhaltefolie und Alufolie
– was ich nicht oft brauche,
nicht oft benutze,
weil ich umweltfreundlich bin,
aber dennoch habe,
weil manchmal braucht man es.
Es ist besser, wenn sie hier links sind.
>> JOSH: Ach so.
>> SALLY: Weil hier rechts stößt man ans Fenster.
>> JOSH: Ah!
Weil wir haben das immer so genommen,
dass man die Frischhaltefolie am Fenster festkleben kann,
dass die dann nicht runterfällt.
[Musik]
>> SALLY: Aha!
Die Rührelemente bleiben plötzlich, wo sie hingehören.
[Musik]
Weißt du, was ich gerne machen würde?
>> JOSH: Was?
>> SALLY: Wie an so einem Tatort
die Umrisse draufzeichnen.
>> JOSH: Ach Gott. Ja.
>> SALLY: Ist doch voll die gute Idee.
>> SARAH: Wenn du es nicht wieder umsortierst.
>> SALLY: Mein Papa hat das an so einer Werkbank
immer gemacht.
Da hat er so den Hammer.
Ich finde das voll gut.
[Musik]
Der Nächste, der die Spülmaschine ausräumt,
der braucht einen Lageplan.
Ich muss einen Plan machen von der Küche.
Ich glaube, sonst drehen sie alle durch.
Alles umgeräumt,
obwohl ich versprochen habe,
ich räume es nie wieder um.
Da kann man nichts machen. Was muss, das muss.
Ordnung ist das halbe Leben.
Und mein ganzes.
Also, falls ihr
mir mal eure Schubladen in der Küche zeigen wollt,
dann schickt mir eine Anfrage, okay?
Ihr müsst auch euer Gesicht nicht zeigen.
Wir müssen nicht zeigen,
welches Gesicht zu welcher Schublade gehört.
Vielleicht das noch dazu.
Es ist halt bei so Live-geh-Themen immer so ein Risiko, nicht?
Wer kommt jetzt live?
"Mein Problem ist die Sache mit den Töpfen."
Ja, ich glaube, das größte Problem ist,
dass man einfach zu viel besitzt.
Und da man dann eben zu viel besitzt,
ist das Problem, dass dann
vieles nicht ineinander reinpasst
und dann eben alles überschwemmt. Ja.
Okay.
Ich glaube, das mit den Anfragen
funktioniert doch nicht so gut, wie ich dachte.
Mh.
Egal.
"Wie bewahrst du Mehl auf, das übrig ist?"
Also ich habe das hier bei mir so.
Guckt mal.
Jetzt machen wir so ein
– eigentlich brauchen wir das Video nicht mehr, Josh.
Wir machen einfach eine Live-Beratung.
>> JOSH: Okay.
>> SALLY: Doch, wir brauchen das Video.
Hier habe ich angebrochene Lebensmittel.
Und hier habe ich halt einen guten Schrank dafür.
Aber, wenn ihr Schubladen habt, dann geht das auch.
Ich habe jetzt hier keine Vorräte in den Schubladen drin.
Aber es gibt ja auch Vorratsdosen,
die praktisch super in die Schublade reinpassen.
Und dann kann man das eben so machen.
Ja, finde ich auch gut.
>> AYSE: Hey!
>> SALLY: Oh! Hu!
Wir haben uns so lange nicht gesehen!
>> AYSE: Ja, und gerade heute sehe ich so schrecklich aus.
>> SALLY: Ach Quatsch! Du siehst gut aus!
>> AYSE: Nee. Ich hatte gerade Homeschooling.
>> SALLY: Echt?
>> AYSE: Ich bin jetzt gerade zu Hause.
>> SALLY: Oh!
Die Ayse und ich, wir haben zusammen studiert.
>> AYSE: Ja, ich habe dich vermisst.
>> SALLY: Ich dich auch.
>> AYSE: Schön, dich zu sehen.
>> AYSE: Und ich bin echt stolz auf dich,
muss ich auch noch mal loswerden.
>> SALLY: Danke!
>> AYSE: Aber ich kann dir auch noch
meinen Problemfall zeigen, liebe Sally.
>> SALLY: Zeig mal. Aber nicht deinen Mann oder so.
>> AYSE: Wie meintest du das?
>> SALLY: Männerproblemfälle kläre ich nicht.
>> AYSE: Nee, der schläft.
Warte. Ich muss kurz die Kamera switchen.
>> SALLY: Oh!
>> AYSE: So.
Ich habe hier so ein Ikea-Küchendingsbums.
>> SALLY: Ja.
>> AYSE: Da sind....
Siehst du es? Egal, wie ich aufräume,
es liegt immer alles querbeet.
Deckel
>> SALLY: Stimmt.
>> AYSE: habe ich irgendwie aufeinander
und das klappt nicht, weil ich es rein- und rausziehe.
>> SALLY: Ja.
>> AYSE: Hier.
>> SALLY: Und da drüber auch Töpfe. Hm.
>> AYSE: Das Problem ist wegen den Töpfen
wegen den Deckeln. Ich kann zwar die Töpfe
ineinanderstecken, aber die Deckel sind das Problem.
Und dadurch, dass es hier nicht so hoch ist,
kann ich auch nicht so viel aufeinanderstapeln.
>> SALLY: Kochst du für eine 20-köpfige Familie
oder warum hast du 20 Töpfe?
>> AYSE: Ja, ich habe eine große Familie.
Ja, jetzt wegen Corona leider nicht,
aber es ist schon ausgemistet worden.
Ich hatte noch mehr Töpfe.
>> SALLY: Echt?
>> AYSE: Das Problem ist, egal, wie ich das ordne,
ich kriege da keine Ordnung rein.
>> SALLY: Ja, gell?
>> AYSE: Es hat nicht funktioniert.
>> SALLY: Aber guck mal. Bei mir passen alle Töpfe
– das sind alle, die ich habe hier.
>> AYSE: Okay.
>> SALLY: Ich habe gar nicht mehr
– okay, außer Gusseisen noch.
Aber die passen hier nicht rein.
Aber ich habe echt nicht viele.
Aber bei dir ist es ja eigentlich gut
mit dem Eckschrank unten, mit diesem Nierenschrank.
>> AYSE: Der ist gut. Nur, ich weiß nicht,
wie ich die Deckel ordnen soll.
Ich ordne alles zehntausendmal, aber
>> SALLY: Ich auch.
>> AYSE: es klappt trotzdem nicht.
>> SALLY: Ich überlege mir was.
Ich überlege mir was.
>> AYSE: Ja, danke!
Und eigentlich wollte ich auch nur dich sehen.
Das war jetzt nur so ein Grund.
>> SALLY: Ich weiß.
Hauptsache, ein Problem ausgepackt.
>> AYSE: Ja.
Ja, schön, dich zu sehen, dass es euch gut geht.
>> SALLY: Oh, ist das schön!
O ja!
Ich glaube, das haben echt viele mit den Vorbereitungen
– mit den Vorratsdosen, dass da so ein Durcheinander ist.
Okay.
Da habe ich mir auch schon ganz viele Sachen gespeichert.
Guck mal,
was ich habe.
>> ZUSCHAUERIN: Ja.
>> SALLY: Ich habe zum einen hier so einen Einteiler.
Der hat so flexible
Seiten.
Das heißt, die kann man auch voll gut verschieben.
Und da habe ich zum Beispiel jetzt alle Deckel drin,
die eben normalerweise immer so rumlappern.
Und den habe ich auch.
Und die sind eigentlich ganz praktisch.
Ich müsste es mal probieren mit den ganzen Vorratsdosen.
>> ZUSCHAUERIN: Hi, Katharina!
>> SALLY: Hallo!
>> KATHARINA: O mein Gott, ey!
>> SALLY: Denn ich habe jetzt hier
auch meine ganzen Vorratsdosen ausgepackt.
Noch nicht alle,
>> ZUSCHAUERIN: Okay.
>> SALLY: aber die muss ich auch gleich verstauen.
Da nehme ich das Problem auch direkt mit rein.
Cool.
Oh, ich finde das war voll das coole Live-Video.
[Musik]
>> VOLKAN: Einen Tag später.
>> SALLY: Ich glaube, eines der größten Probleme ist es,
Backformen zu verstauen, vor allem, wenn man viele hat.
Ich habe jetzt hier oben mal
die Schublade ganz gut sortiert, muss ich sagen.
Ich hatte hier immer ein bisschen ein Durcheinander,
weil immer die Backfolien sich aufgerollt haben.
Hier gibt es aber auch einen Tipp.
Wenn ihr die Backfolie in der Verpackung lasst
und immer wieder in die Verpackung mit reingebt,
dann habt ihr einfach den Karton,
der die Folie schützt und der die Folie immer in Form hält.
Genauso beim Backpapier.
Da hatte ich eigentlich immer
das Bedürfnis, das Backpapier auszupacken,
damit einfach es einheitlich aussieht.
Aber im Karton ist es doch besser.
Und jetzt habe ich hier auch den SpaceFlexx mal eingebaut
und habe jetzt auch hier drunter sogar Platz für Vorräte.
Jetzt rutscht nichts mehr hin und her.
Ich habe die Handschuhe hier drin.
Ich habe sogar noch Platz für meine Backformen,
also für die Baguette-Formen,
und habe das jetzt hier sicher verstaut.
Und dann gibt es noch diese anderen Backformen,
Muffinformen, Springformen, Donutformen,
und die sind hier.
Die habe ich jetzt hier mal übereinander gelagert.
Also, falls ihr wirklich keinen Schrank habt,
in dem ihr es hochkant reinstellen könnt,
müsst ihr es leider übereinander stapeln.
Aber ich zeige euch jetzt einen anderen Trick.
Denn da habe ich jetzt gedacht,
die packe ich jetzt auch von hier da rüber.
Und dann kann ich sie auch einzeln rausnehmen
und es verrutscht nichts mehr und fällt nichts um.
[Musik]
Ich bin mir so unschlüssig.
>> SARAH: Womit?
>> SALLY: Soll ich die Schrift nehmen?
>> SARAH: Da kann man die Schriftarten einstellen?
>> SALLY: Ja.
>> SARAH: Das ist was für Freaks, Sally.
Das ist echt crazy.
>> SALLY: Aber soll ich die Schriftart?
Ich finde die schon
– also entweder die,
American
Typewriter.
Josh? Aylin?
>> AYLIN: Die ist cool.
>> SALLY: Oder
>> JOSH: Ach,
>> SARAH: Gut, ja.
>> JOSH: findest du?
>> SALLY: Oh, das ist so eine Schreibschrift
– Schreibmaschinenschrift.
Oder die.
>> SARAH: Ich bin für die.
>> SALLY: Oder die.
>> SARAH: Nee, ich bin so was von für Bodoni 72 Oldstyle.
>> AYLIN: Ja, finde ich auch gut.
[Musik]
>> SALLY: Ha?
Ich
>> SAMIRA: Mama, was hast du da gemacht?
>> SALLY: finde es
>> SARAH: Bedruckt.
Das ist echt schön.
>> SALLY: schön.
>> SARAH: Ja.
>> SAMIRA: Zeig mal.
>> SARAH: Perfekt!
>> SALLY: Zu klein?
Sollen wir es größer schreiben?
>> SARAH: Ein bisschen klein finde ich es. Ja.
>> SALLY: Gell? Ein bisschen größer.
>> SALLY: Konnte ich dich überzeugen?
>> SAMIRA: Langsam.
>> SARAH: Ja, schon.
>> SALLY: Beim Baiser denke ich mir so:
Müssen wir Baiser beschriften?
Weil man sieht es doch.
Aber wir beschriften alles.
Zarte Haferflocken.
[Musik]
Guck mal. Und dann hier einfach
zum Beispiel San-apart.
"San-apart".
Und dann aber kein Leerzeichen,
also das Leerzeichen wegmachen.
>> SAMIRA: Hm.
>> SALLY: "Fertig".
"Drucken".
Und auf die Rechtschreibung achten.
Okay? Also eigentlich kannst du nichts falsch machen
>> SAMIRA: Aber guck mal.
>> SALLY: außer wenn...
>> SAMIRA: San-apart.
>> SALLY: Ich schreibe aber San-apart zusammen.
Und ich tu es dann
– ich schneide es dann weg.
Und jetzt schreibst du
"Vanilleextrakt".
[Musik]
So macht es plötzlich Spaß, der Mama zu helfen.
>> SAMIRA: Ist das so richtig?
>> SALLY: Vanilleextrakt, genau.
Und jetzt das Leerzeichen weg.
Wieder zurück, ja.
Und jetzt auf "Fertig" und auf "Drucken".
Ja.
Perfekt.
>> SAMIRA: Kommt jetzt Tonka Wonka?
[Musik]
>> VOLKAN: Wieder einen Tag später.
>> SALLY: So. Jetzt nur noch die letzten Schritte.
Dann bin ich fertig und zeige euch,
was ich organisiert habe
und was es für Tipps und Tricks gibt.
Aber eine Sache muss ich noch etikettieren.
[Musik]
Willkommen also in meiner organisierten Küche!
Das Schlimme ist, dass man von außen nie sieht,
was passiert ist.
Denn die Küche sieht jetzt genauso aus wie vorher
von außen.
Aber von innen ist sie jetzt strukturiert und aufgeräumt.
Das Arbeiten fällt einfacher.
Es bleibt die Ordnung.
Denn es ist ja gar nicht so wichtig,
die Ordnung hinzubekommen.
Also einmal ordentlich gemacht ist wirklich super schnell.
Das macht auch jeder mal gerne.
Aber die Ordnung zu halten, das ist das Wichtige.
Und da gebe ich euch jetzt Tipps und Tricks.
Ich würde sagen, wir gehen einfach
durch die einzelnen Küchenzonen,
so, wie ich sie euch anfangs vorgestellt habe,
und ich zeige euch, wie ich es eingeräumt habe
und wie ich hoffe, dass die Ordnung eben auch bleibt.
Fangen wir direkt an mit dem Herz der Küche,
nämlich die Vorbereitungszone.
In dieser Zone bereitet ihr praktisch alle Lebensmittel vor.
Ihr schneidet, ihr rührt,
ihr fügt vielleicht auch noch Gewürze dazu.
Also in dieser Vorbereitungszone ist wirklich alles,
was vor dem Kochen oder vor dem Backen geschieht.
Und das ist bei mir hier.
Deswegen habe ich hier in den Schränken und Schubladen
alles, was ich hier zum Vorbereiten brauche,
also meine Schneidebretter,
ich habe aber auch große Rührschüsseln,
Salatschleuder, die bei mir oft zum Einsatz kommt,
aber auch genauso gut die Kochblume,
also mein Überkochschutz,
meine Faltsiebe hier ganz ordentlich sortiert.
Und da war es auch immer so, dass die immer gerne
in der Schublade durcheinandergefallen sind.
Und ich hatte sie dann versucht
mal in das eine Ecke zu klemmen,
dann ins andere Eck,
dann zwischen zwei Schüsseln geklemmt, die Deckel.
Aber, sobald du halt dann die Salatschleuder rausnimmst,
war es halt dann doch wieder ein Durcheinander.
Deswegen habe ich jetzt hier den SpaceFlexx mal eingebaut.
Und ich finde, das hält auch hier ganz gut.
Hier oben habe ich dann, weil ich zum Vorbereiten
– das ist jetzt sehr individuell.
Ich brauche zum Vorbereiten meine vielen Glasschüsseln
und Glasschälchen in verschiedenen Größen,
weil ich ja hier immer Zutaten abwiege für die Kamerafahrt.
Und deswegen habe ich auch so viele.
Und die hatte ich früher dahinten am Spülbecken.
Aber da macht es gar keinen Sinn.
Denn ich brauche es hier, wiege es
und lege es dann hier direkt auf die Küchentheke.
Und die habe ich jetzt hier auch schön organisiert.
Und das Wichtige ist, dass eben auch jemand,
der nicht mit mir hier dreht
oder vielleicht nicht jeden Tag mit mir in der Küche ist,
und wenn jetzt mal jemand die Spülmaschine ausräumt
wie der Volkan oder der Siamak oder der Benny,
einer, der oben viel arbeitet,
dass er trotzdem weiß, wo alles hingehört.
Und deswegen habe ich teilweise
Dinge eben auch beschriftet,
so wie jetzt hier "Messbecher mini".
Denn, wenn ich jetzt, sage ich mal,
alle fünf meiner Messbecher in Gebrauch habe
und die in der Spülmaschine sind,
weiß man ja im Prinzip nicht mehr, wo kommt es hin.
Und deswegen entsteht eben immer die Unordnung.
Wenn ihr da aber teilweise eben
Beschriftungen mit dazu bringt und anklebt,
dann weiß jeder, aha, da ist der Messbecher.
Und dieses System habe ich damals
auch in der Schulküche gemacht,
als ich selbst noch Lehrerin war.
Ich habe dann nämlich die ganzen Schulküche etikettiert,
habe aber auch teilweise mit Bildern gearbeitet
und habe sozusagen so immer die Ordnung halten können,
weil dann jeder Schüler wusste, wo kommt was hin.
Es wurde auch noch die Anzahl hingeschrieben,
weil du hast ja in der Küche auch verschiedene Küchenzeilen,
vier Gruppen zum Beispiel.
Und dann war immer da gestanden
"10 Messer" hier, "5 Messer" da.
Und dann wusste man eben immer, wo alles hingehört.
Und dann habe ich auch hier meine Küchenwaagen.
Und wenn jetzt hier auch alle in Betrieb wären,
steht hier einfach drunter die "Waage".
Jeder weiß, aha, die Waage kommt da hin.
Genauso habe ich hier auch meine kleinen Messlöffel,
die ich immer brauche, oder eben auch die Messbecher.
Und selbst da habe ich dann auch was druntergeklebt,
dass jeder weiß, wo die hinkommen.
Direkt darüber habe ich eine Schublade,
da haben wir jetzt auch lange überlegt, was wir machen.
Im Prinzip habe ich jetzt hier alles drin,
was ich wirklich immer hier brauche.
Ich habe zum einen mein Besteck jetzt auch da,
weil wir auch hier verkosten.
Und das Besteck war vorher dort.
Der Esstisch ist aber dort.
Hier wird verkostet.
Also es war echt so ein bisschen unorganisiert.
Jeder wusste zwar, wo es steckt,
aber man hat halt wirklich gerade in einer großen Küche
und in einem großen Raum viele, viele Laufwege.
Jetzt haben wir hier einen Teil des Bestecks für hier
zum Anrichten, Servieren und Probieren
und aber auch einen Teil des Bestecke vorne
an unserem Esstisch,
dass wir einfach dort einen kürzeren Laufweg haben.
Hier habe ich zum Beispiel auch,
weil ich hier auch immer die Torten anschneide,
meine Kuchenheber und Tortenheber,
kleine Messer, aber auch Schneebesen zum Beispiel
oder diese Untersetzer, die eben hitzebeständig sind,
aber auch als Rutschschutz
– also den Rutschschutz bieten.
Und ich musste mich hier so ein bisschen umgewöhnen,
weil es einfach so ist:
Ich hatte normalerweise
– das gehört ja auch hier zur Vorbereitungszone.
Hier hatte ich zum Beispiel immer
meine ganzen Gefu-Werkzeuge,
also alles, was ich zum Zerkleinern,
Vermischen und so weiter brauche.
Und jeder wusste, das ist die Gefu-Schublade.
Da war alles drin.
Aber es gibt halt Dinge, die brauche ich
wirklich täglich und wöchentlich,
und Dinge, die brauche ich nicht so oft.
Deswegen habe ich es auch hier umstrukturiert
und habe gesagt, okay,
meine Küchenmaschine, die KitchenAid steht hier,
also brauche ich da direkt drunter auch die Rührelemente.
Und da hatte ich jetzt bisher
auch immer keine Möglichkeit zur Aufbewahrung
und habe die jetzt hier
auch in so einen SpaceFlexx einfach reinsortiert,
weil hier die schmalen drinstehen, hier die größeren,
aber genauso auch diese Einfüllhilfen, die Abdeckungen
und hier zum Beispiel dann eben
auch die Werkzeuge, die ich oft brauche.
Das heißt, auch hier habe ich es so gemacht.
Guckt mal. Wenn man jetzt hier den Transforma rausnimmt
samt Zubehör
und jemand außer mir hier aufräumt,
dann weiß er einfach, hier steht "Transforma" drin
und da kommt das eben wieder zurück.
Und im Prinzip ist ja hier erst mal gar nicht wichtig,
welche Einteiler ihr nehmt,
sondern dass ihr einfach Einteiler habt.
Ich habe früher in unseren Wohnungen
auch gerne mal in der Büroabteilung geguckt.
Da gibt es ja auch Einteiler für Schubladen, für Schränke.
Es gibt Badezimmereinteiler.
Es gibt Kücheneinteiler.
Da muss man sich halt sagen, wie viel Budget habe ich.
Also man kann ja auch so kleine Körbchen und Kisten nehmen.
Man kann sich auch was selber basteln
aus Karton zum Beispiel.
Ich habe mich letztendlich jetzt hier für die entschieden,
weil ich jetzt weiß, die sind bei mir in der Küche.
Ich habe diese Einteiler, die fest sind.
Ich habe die flexiblen Einteiler,
die ich zum Beispiel auch im Schlafzimmer benutzen kann,
also bei der Wäsche, bei Strumpfhosen, bei Unterwäsche,
bei Oberteilen, die zusammengerollt werden.
Und da gibt es ja wirklich verschiedene.
Hauptsache, ihr habt es halt irgendwie eingeteilt.
Genauso hier.
Hier habe ich zum Beispiel auch ein Foto
von euch bekommen
mit ganz wirren Schubladen,
die wirklich teilweise einfach überfüllt sind,
aber teilweise einfach nicht sortiert sind.
Und damit ihr
die Sortierung eben auch danach beibehalten könnt,
solltet ihr eben eine Aufteilung haben.
Das heißt, dass auch, wenn euer Ehepartner einräumt
oder die Kinder die Spülmaschine ausräumen,
dass die auch wissen, was wohin kommt.
Und so habe ich es hier jetzt zum Beispiel auch.
Also ich habe hier meine ganzen Teigschaber.
Ich habe hier meine Pinsel.
Ich habe hier mein Kochbesteck,
hier die Löffelablagen.
Und im Normalfall sieht ja jetzt hier auch jeder,
was wohin kommt.
Und dann kommt es eben auch nicht durcheinander.
Aber, wenn ihr sagt, da ist es auch immer ein Durcheinander,
dann beschriftet es einfach untendrunter wieder.
Und dann weiß auch jeder,
wo die Eislöffel, die Eisportionierer hinkommen.
Dann weiß jeder, hier ist Schneidebesteck.
Ich glaube, ich muss es auch noch mal beschriften, Josh.
Ich sehe es schon kommen.
>> JOSH: Ja.
>> SALLY: Ich werde hier das untendrunter auch etikettieren.
Weil sonst suche ich wieder meine Eisbereiter,
meine Eisportionierer.
Ja, und weil ich hier, wie gesagt,
auch immer viele Schüsseln brauche,
da habe ich ja vorne die zum Abwiegen
und hier habe ich einfach meine Rührschüsseln,
zum einen die Rührschüsseln von der Küchenmaschine
und zum anderen große Rührschüsseln,
in denen ich eben auch Teig, Massen,
Salate und so weiter verrühre.
Ja.
Das war die Vorbereitungszone.
Jetzt kommen wir zur Kochzone.
Und hier an der Kochzone habe ich alles,
was ich zum Kochen brauche.
Das heißt zum einen Olivenöl.
Ich habe Salz und Pfeffer.
Die hatte ich eigentlich immer hier draußen.
Aber ich will so wenig wie möglich
immer draußen stehen haben.
Deswegen habe ich jetzt hier in dem kleinen Apothekerauszug
einfach meine Salz- und Pfeffermühle drin
und recht weit außen platziert.
Das heißt, wenn ich jetzt nur Salz und Pfeffer brauche,
muss ich auch nicht die komplette Schublade öffnen,
sondern kann mir hier die Salz- und Pfeffermühle
einfach rausholen.
Das ist ganz gut.
Unten drin habe ich Öl, Essig und alle weiteren Zutaten
wie auch Sojasoße oder andere Soßen, die ich hier brauche.
Ich habe jetzt hier den Ausdruck nicht nur als Kochauszug,
sondern auch als Backauszug,
weil es auch Sachen sind, die ich oft brauche beim Backen.
Und ihr könnt auch hier,
um das Ganze thematisch so abzugrenzen,
mit so kleinen Kisten arbeiten.
Und die Kisten könnte man sogar,
wenn man sie braucht, einfach rausstellen,
wieder reinstellen.
Und dann könnt ihr so zum Beispiel auch Gewürze sortieren
und Gewürze eben miteinander kombinieren
oder eben Backzutaten.
Direkt unter dem Herd habe ich
in der unteren Schublade meine Töpfe und Pfannen.
Und da haben mir auch ganz viele gesagt,
dass sie gerade beim Töpfe- und Pfannensortieren
immer viele Probleme haben.
Ich glaube, es liegt oft aber einfach dran, dass man zu viel hat.
Denn ich muss sagen, wir kochen hier viel,
aber im Prinzip reicht mir die halbe Schublade.
Denn ich habe nur so eine schmale Schublade,
um das alles hier zu verstauen.
Ich muss aber auch dazu sagen,
dass ich recht wenig Edelstahl- oder Kupfertöpfe habe.
Denn ich arbeite ja auch viel mit Gusseisen.
Und die habe ich jetzt entweder oft hier auf dem Herd stehen
oder einfach dahinten.
Ich nutze die halt auch als Dekoration, muss ich sagen,
weil sie schön sind,
und habe es dann eben nicht mit hier in der Schublade,
sondern eben auf Regalen oder auf dem Tisch stehen.
Und die Deckel habe ich dann einfach so organisiert,
dass ich hier auch so einen Einteiler habe
und da alle Deckel auf die linke Seite gepackt habe,
die Töpfe ineinander, die Stieltöpfe ineinander
und die Pfannen ineinander.
Und mehr habe ich im Prinzip auch gar nicht.
Was ihr auch machen könnt:
Ihr könnt auch die Deckel nehmen
und den Deckel umdrehen,
auf den Topf legen,
den nächsten Topf obendrauf.
Dann habt ihr direkt den Deckel praktisch auf dem Topf,
wenn es von der Höhe her passt.
Wisst ihr, die Problemlösung fängt beim Umdenken an
und der Mensch ist ein Gewohnheitstier.
Das heißt, man hat es eingetrichtert bekommen,
Töpfe und Pfannen gehören unter den Herd,
Töpfe und Pfannen müssen dorthin, wo die Kochstelle ist.
Macht ja auch Sinn,
dass man es nicht ans andere Ende der Küche räumt.
Aber was uns hier gerade aufgefallen ist:
Ich habe diese schweren Töpfe und Pfannen hier unten drin,
muss mich ständig bücken.
Und eigentlich macht es so wenig Sinn.
Und gerade gestern haben wir beim Umräumen noch gesagt,
dass wir die Schränke hier hinten, die Schubladen
viel zu uneffizient nutzen.
Deswegen räumen wir das kurz um,
damit wir hier unten leichte Dinge haben
wie zum Beispiel eine Gugelhupfbackform,
meine Gärkörbchen fürs Brotbacken
und alles, was ich eben auch mal brauche, aber nicht so häufig.
Denn am besten ist es, ihr räumt eure Küche ergonomisch ein.
Ergonomisch bedeutet:
Alles, was schwer ist, am besten auf die Höhe,
dass ihr es gut tragen könnt.
Nicht viel bücken, aber auch nicht hochstrecken.
Ergonomisch einräumen bedeutet für mich
so zwischen Augenhöhe und Kniehöhe
und nicht unter der Kniehöhe die Töpfe.
Und deswegen räumen wir jetzt hier geschwind um.
Komm, Josh.
Das machen wir zusammen.
[Musik]
Jetzt haben wir den Kochbereich auch optimiert.
Wenn ich jetzt hier am Herd stehe
und Töpfe und Pfannen brauche,
dann muss ich mich nicht sehr bücken.
Denn ich habe jetzt hier einfach meine Töpfe
direkt mit dem Deckel drauf.
Wenn ihr weniger Platz habt als ich,
einfach ineinander stapeln
und die Topfdeckel einfach dazulegen.
Und ich kann halt hier auch ganz gut
einfach mal mit dem Knie dagegen,
wenn ich was in der Hand habe,
und kann jetzt hier auf einer Höhe
wirklich meine Töpfe und Pfannen eben rausnehmen.
Und es waren jetzt neuneinhalb Minuten
>> JOSH: Ja.
>> SALLY: umräumen.
Und das spart uns jetzt echt Rückenschmerzen,
muss man echt dazu sagen.
Wir müssen uns nur im Kopf praktisch umgewöhnen,
dass eben
die Töpfe nicht mehr da unten sind,
sondern hier.
Wir haben es einfacher.
Hier habe ich meine Gewürzschublade,
eben die Gewürze, die ich hier zum Kochen und Backen
täglich brauche.
Und ich weiß, wahrscheinlich hat kein Mensch außer mir
so viele Gewürze zu Hause.
Aber ich habe eben einige.
Die sind auch alle beschriftet.
Und auch da einen Tipp:
Wenn ihr nicht möchtet,
dass eure Gewürze durcheinanderkommen,
dann beschriftet das Gewürz an sich
und auch den Stellplatz.
Also es sollte auf dem Gewürz stehen und drunter stehen.
Dann macht es auch keiner
– bringt es keiner durcheinander.
Und ich habe hier ein Holzteile,
was die Gewürze an Ort und Stelle lässt.
Das hat mit der Josh zugeschnitten.
Das war ein Geburtstagsgeschenk.
Er weiß, wie er mich glücklich macht.
Kontextlos klingt es komisch,
aber im Kontext mit der Schublade
kann es jeder nachvollziehen.
>> JOSH: Ja.
>> SALLY: Ja.
Genau. Und auch hier,
wenn ihr andere Gewürzdosen habt,
wenn ihr Gewürze nicht so häufig braucht wie ich,
lasst sie einfach in ihren Originalbehältern.
Aber was ich immer gut finde:
Wenn ihr so Tütchen habt,
die würde ich schon immer umfüllen.
Weil die sehen schnell unordentlich aus.
Also entweder nehmt euch Gewürzdosen
oder nehmt einfach Gewürze direkt in der Verpackung.
Ich habe auch hier zum Beispiel vom Stefan noch,
vom Stefan Marquard Gewürze.
Die lasse ich natürlich in der Verpackung.
Die sind praktisch.
Man sieht von oben, was drin ist.
Und wie gesagt, habe ich hier
so ein bisschen die Kochgewürze,
hier die Backgewürze
und in der Mitte habe ich hier noch die Gewürzmischungen.
Und die sind eigentlich echt gut sortiert.
Und hier habe ich auch,
seitdem ich die Holzplatte habe vom Josh
und seitdem ich alles beschriftet und etikettiert habe,
echt auch kein Durcheinander mehr.
Weil es kann halt keiner hergehen
und Lorbeerblätter zum Dill stellen oder andersrum.
Das ist dann schon gut.
Und da könnt ihr es auch direkt so machen,
wenn ihr auch alles beschriftet:
Im Beschriftungsgerät beziehungsweise in der App
könnt ihr ja einfach zweimal drucken
und dann spart ihr euch am Ende die Arbeit.
Also überlegt euch einfach im Vorfeld,
was wollt ihr alles beschriften
und wie oft braucht ihr das Etikett.
So habe ich es hier nämlich auch gemacht.
Da konnte ich dann direkt einfach
einmal nur "Lorbeerblatt" schreiben, doppelt drucken
beziehungsweise ich habe es sogar dann viermal gedruckt.
Denn ich habe ja hier eine Küche und drüben eine Küche.
Und dann spart man sich halt im Endeffekt
dieses doppelte und dreifache Etikettieren.
Ja, also so viel dazu.
Und ich habe hier rechts vom Kochfeld
auch noch mal so einen Kochassistenten.
Der ist bei uns teilweise belegt,
weil wir hier noch den Staubsauger drin haben,
der praktisch hier
mit unserer zentralen Staubsaugeranlage gekoppelt ist.
Wenn das nicht wäre, hätte ich hier
natürlich auch noch ein bisschen mehr Platz.
Aber hier habe ich sogar einen Schrank, der recht leer ist
und den ich jetzt auch gar nicht
auf Biegen und Brechen füllen möchte,
sondern wir machen ja hier ganz oft Porridge.
Eigentlich fast jeden Tag unter der Woche
gibt es bei uns Haferbrei.
Dazu brauchen wir immer jeden Tag den Stampfer,
weil wir immer Bananen reinstampfen.
Deswegen haben wir den hier reingepackt
und gar nicht zum Silikonbesteck.
Ich brauche jeden Tag eine Zitruspresse.
Die habe ich jetzt auch hier drin.
Ich habe hier meine Scheren gut organisiert
und zum Beispiel auch Aufstriche,
die ich echt immer auch fürs Porridge zum Beispiel nehme,
einmal unser Yammlou, unser Mandelmus.
Für den Josh haben wir hier immer Nougat.
Und da unten eben auch unsere Küchenrolle.
Also das ist so etwas, was wir echt hier immer brauchen.
Das war jetzt eigentlich sozusagen der Kochbereich.
Was ich noch habe,
was ein bisschen abgekoppelt vom Spülbereich ist
– den Spülbereich habe ich euch ja schon gezeigt
beim Einräumen.
Wir haben unsere Küchentücher hier rübergeräumt.
Wir haben zwar den Spülbereich da vorne,
aber, wenn wir drehen, spülen wir auch teilweise hier,
damit der Hintergrund dort recht leer ist.
Und ich habe ja ein zweites Spülbecken.
Hier hängen wir auch die Spültücher auf zum Trocknen.
Und deswegen habe ich sie jetzt auch hier rübergeräumt,
weil ich hier einfach den Platz dafür habe
und die hier eben besser verstaut sind.
Und vor allem habe ich hier so eine Schublade,
die ich nicht ganz nutzen kann,
weil eben das Spülbecken drunter ist.
Und da passt es echt mit Geschirrtüchern gut.
Und die Schublade hier unten ist wirklich nur noch für Dinge,
die ich nicht häufig brauche,
genauso wie die Schublade jetzt unterm Herd
einfach für Backformen, für leichte Sachen,
die eben nicht jeden Tag zum Einsatz kommen,
damit ich mich nicht jeden Tag herunterbücken muss.
Ja, dann kommen wir im Prinzip
schon direkt zum
Backbereich.
Der Backbereich ist ja praktisch der Backofenbereich.
Wenn ihr die Möglichkeit habt,
dann verstaut eure Backbleche direkt über
oder direkt unter dem Backofen.
Wenn ihr gar keinen Platz habt
– das habe ich auch auf vielen Fotos gesehen.
Ich finde es halt immer unpraktisch,
wenn man Backbleche im Backofen verstaut,
weil, sobald ihr den Backofen in Benutzung habt,
müssen die Backbleche ja in der Küche stehen.
Und das sieht halt echt immer unordentlich aus.
Aber, wenn ihr keinen Platz habt, in den Backofen rein.
Ansonsten gibt es ja oft eine Schublade drunter.
Ich hatte auch
– als ich die Kindergartenküche eingeräumt habe,
war auch ein Backofen unten eingebaut
und drunter noch mal so eine kleine Schublade.
Da passt auch immer ganz viel rein.
Oder eben, wie gesagt, darüber.
Und hier könnt ihr euch ganz einfach
so was an die Wand montieren,
das heißt, dass die Backbleche wirklich übereinander,
aber trotzdem in Fächern sortiert werden können.
Was noch praktischer ist:
Wenn ihr das Ganze einmal dreht
und die Backbleche so reinschiebt.
Das fände ich persönlich praktischer.
Das habe ich jetzt nicht gefunden.
Ich habe es jetzt auch so gelassen.
Aber ich glaube, für die Zukunft werde ich das so machen,
dass ich das Ganze drehe und hochkant reinschiebe.
Falls ihr auch eine Kaffeemaschine in eurer Küche habt,
dann schaut am besten
– entweder ist es eine integrierte
oder wahrscheinlich so ein Standgerät.
Und wenn ihr da Platz habt,
am besten drüber oder drunter direkt die Tassen.
Wir haben es auch so, wir haben hier jetzt die Tassen drin.
Wir haben einfach viele verschiedene,
auch direkt die Löffel mit dabei.
Denn dann muss ich nicht extra zur Besteckschublade.
Weil das sind eigentlich nur Kaffee- oder Teelöffel,
die eben auch für Espressotassen
oder für türkische Teetassen geeignet sind.
Und die brauche ich nicht extra
in meine Besteckschublade stecken,
sondern die sind hier wirklich perfekt.
Zucker habe ich jetzt hier gar nicht mit dabei.
Der steht bei uns am Tisch.
Aber ansonsten habe ich auch hier drüber direkt die Gläser,
weil auch sich hier jeder merken kann,
Gläser, Kaffee, Getränke gibt es hier.
Hier auch Tee- und Kaffeevorrat.
Und ich habe ganz unten auch bei uns in der privaten Küche
immer eine Schublade,
an die die Kinder kommen,
und zwar mit Tassen und kleinen Schälchen und Tellern.
Da haben wir jetzt unsere Emaillegeschirr drin,
weil die das ganz gerne benutzen.
Ich benutze es auch gern.
Und das ist einfach da unten.
Es ist leicht, man kommt gut dran.
Und wie gesagt, ich persönlich finde das hier ganz gut,
weil eben die Kinder drankommen.
Ansonsten hätte ich es, weil ich es sehr oft benutze
– ich hatte es auch vorher hier drin.
Aber da muss ich jedes Mal hinlaufen
und den Kindern alles geben.
Deswegen haben wir es jetzt umgeräumt,
bis die halt groß werden.
Ja.
So. Da muss man Abstriche machen.
Was ich hier oben noch habe:
Wir haben hier so ein Drehrondell drin.
Und zwar haben wir hier angebrochene Dinge wie Honig,
Pasten,
Fruchtsirup und so weiter
und auch Dinge, an die Ela
vielleicht nicht so gut drankommen sollte.
Denn, wenn es nach Ela ginge,
würde sie überall Schokosoße drüberhauen.
Und das darf sie natürlich nicht, nur bedingt.
Deswegen haben wir das hier.
Eigentlich, Josh
– es tut mir leid, aber ich muss dein Nougat
wieder hier hoch räumen.
Der war ja vorher auch da oben.
Denn ich kenne Ela.
Die löffelt das dann weg.
Das machen wir nicht.
>> JOSH: Ist okay.
>> SALLY: Da oben habe ich dann noch
mein Werkzeug für Torten.
Also ich habe ja hier meine Pinsel
in meinem Drehrondell eben drin.
Und hier hinten das kann ich euch mal zeigen.
Denn da habe ich auch ganz viele Bilder gesehen,
dass ihr eben auch viel Krimskrams habt,
was jetzt doch keinen Platz hat irgendwo.
Und da habe ich jetzt hier einfach solche Kisten
mit Ausstechern zum Beispiel,
die auch beschriftet.
Die muss ich auch teilweise
noch ein bisschen umbeschriften, muss ich sagen.
Aber das sind jetzt die, die ich hier häufiger brauche.
Ich habe natürlich ganz viele Ausstecher.
Also ich habe da oben noch diese Schränke alle voll,
weil da einfach Sachen drin sind,
die ich eben nicht jeden Tag brauche.
Falls ihr auch ganz, ganz oben Schränke habt,
könnt ihr die auch nutzen.
Einfach durchsichtige Boxen nehmen,
beschriften von vorne.
Dann sieht man auch, was drin ist und was drin steckt.
Dann auch immer die häufige Frage:
Was mache ich mit meinem Küchenmaschinenzubehör?
Also, wenn ihr einen festen Platz
für eure Küchenmaschine habt, so wie ich die hier,
– die KitchenAid ist dort, die Kenwood ist hier –
dann packt euer Zubehör auch wirklich dorthin.
Ich habe, muss ich sagen, extremst viel Zubehör,
weil ich aber auch die ganzen Technik- und
Produktvideos mache, um euch alles zu erklären.
Aber auch ich benutze ja nicht alles.
Und deswegen sind die Zubehörteile,
die ich selber selten benutze oder gar nicht benutze,
komplett wegverräumt, also da oben im Schrank.
Und die Zubehörteile, die ich immer brauche,
sind direkt drunter so wie jetzt hier.
Die Rührelemente habe ich hier, den Multizerkleinerer.
Den brauche ich wirklich fast täglich.
Dann habe ich hier auch noch mal
mit diesem flexiblen Einteiler einfach alles reinorganisiert,
was sonst immer umfällt.
Und hier habe ich ja auch eher so meine Backsachen.
Also dort im Bereich sind eher die Kochsachen,
hier eher so die Backsachen.
Das heißt, ich habe hier zum Beispiel auch
meine Zwischenschublade
und habe hier die Universal-
– die Backmatte,
dann eben die ganzen Ausrollhölzer
beziehungsweise Ausrollstäbe.
Ich habe hier alles, was mit Spritzbeuteln, Spritztüllen zu tun hat,
eben auch die Vorräte
oder auch die ganzen Winkelpaletten,
Teigkarten und eben kleinen Paletten.
Und da könnt ihr auch entweder mit Einteilern arbeiten
oder mit so kleinen Körben und Kisten.
Ich könnte jetzt auch theoretisch hergehen und sagen,
ich nehme die Kiste jetzt mal mit vorne auf den Tisch.
Das brauche ich aber nicht,
weil ich hier echt auch ganz gut drankomme an alles.
Und was ich hier zum Beispiel gemacht habe
mit der Tortensäge,
weil ich für die nie einen richtigen Platz gefunden habe,
die aber einfach so schön flach ist,
aber trotzdem zu hoch, um sie in die Schublade zu packen:
Wir haben sie hier einfach an den Rand geklebt.
Und wenn ich sie brauche, nehme ich sie da weg.
Und wenn nicht mehr, klebe ich sie einfach wieder hin.
Und da verliere ich sie nicht
und weiß einfach, wo sie ist.
Und so was wie hier, ein Oklava,
also so ein großer, langer Ausrollstab,
der auch kaum irgendwo reinpasst.
Meine Mutter, die hatte den immer auf dem Kühlschrank,
weil sie auch keinen Platz dafür hatte.
Ich hatte hier hinten einfach eine Lücke
und habe die da jetzt reingequetscht.
Ja.
Und größere Dinge wie zum Beispiel
die Rührschüssel
oder auch mein Entsafter, den ich zurzeit echt häufig benutze,
habe ich jetzt hier unten mit drin
und eben auch die Vorratsdosen, was ich euch erklärt habe.
Das heißt, alles, was hier im Bereich ist
in Richtung Kühlschrank,
sind eben auch Vorratsdosen, Vorratsbehälter.
Auch hier unten
einmal aus Glas, einmal die aus Kunststoff.
Hier habe ich aber auch die Eisbereiter,
die ich zum Beispiel benutze,
um Tomatenmark oder Paprikamark einzufrieren
oder auch weitere Zutaten.
Und hier obendrüber eben die Geräte,
die ich von dort hier rübergeräumt habe,
die ich auch nicht so häufig brauche.
Das heißt, ein Handrührgeräte brauche ich oft.
Das ist dort.
Meinen Stabmixer, den brauche ich nicht so oft.
Der ist hier.
Dann haben wir hier eben
auch noch so einen Spiralschneider,
den ich halt auch nicht so oft brauche,
oder zum Beispiel hier die KitchenAid-Nudelwalzen.
Ich mache jetzt auch nicht jeden Tag Nudeln.
Aber, wenn ihr das macht,
dann solltet ihr die wirklich weiter drüben aufbewahren.
Und hier oben, um den Bereich Aufbewahren abzuschließen,
habe ich hier noch Frischhaltefolie und Alufolie,
die ich nicht häufig brauche.
Aber man hat es halt einfach.
Und eben auch so Sachen wie Gefrierbeutel,
die Thermometer, die Stretchys oder so kleine Verschlüsse.
Also da passt alles schon auch thematisch zusammen.
Bienenwachstücher, die ich auch mal gerne nehme,
oder auch hier Schaschlikspieße und so weiter.
Also das ist alles hier,
weil ich es halt echt nicht so häufig brauche.
Nicht runterfallen!
Ich habe dich dahin sortiert.
In einem schwäbischen Haushalt
wäre das Spätzlebrett
da vorne,
da bei den Schneidebrettern.
In einem badischen Haushalt ist das Spätzlebrett weiter weg,
weil in Baden nicht so häufig Spätzle gemacht werden.
Stimmst du mir zu?
>> JOSH: Ja. Ha ja.
>> SALLY: Oder?
>> JOSH: Stimmt, stimmt.
>> SALLY: Es ist so.
Ich glaube, das Problem
oder das größte Problem beim Aufräumen,
habe ich aus euren Kommentaren gelesen,
ist, dass ihr zu viele Vorratsbehälter habt.
Also ich habe die Schubladen mir angeguckt.
Und das war eigentlich schon immer so.
Das Problem war zu viele und zu viele unterschiedliche.
Und ich muss auch sagen, ich hatte
– in meiner alten Wohnung –
ich hatte
drei oder vier Schieber voll mit Vorratsdosen.
Und es waren halt kleine, eckige, runde,
hohe, tiefe, durchsichtige, nicht durchsichtige,
transparent, nicht transparent.
Ich habe alles radikal ausgemistet,
weil ich gesagt habe, nee.
Weil zum einen wollte ich es einheitlicher haben
und habe auch viel auf Glas umgestellt, muss ich sagen.
Und zum anderen,
wenn man sich das echt mal überlegt,
man braucht nicht so, so, so viele.
Ich habe jetzt hier immer noch viele, muss ich sagen.
Also eigentlich für einen normalen Haushalt,
finde ich, reicht ein Schieber voll.
Und dann kann man sagen,
komm, die Deckel hier hinsortieren.
Und das kann man hier auch ganz gut mit Einteilern machen
und kann hier wirklich alles schön
auch verschieden groß einklemmen,
dass nichts mehr umfällt.
Ich habe hier halt eine große Küche,
weil wir hier ja jeden Tag drei, vier Videos machen.
Ich mache Backbücher, Kochbücher.
Und ich habe einfach viel zum Verstauen.
Und dafür finde ich zwei
oder es sind sogar nur eineinhalb Schieber,
recht gut.
Das heißt, schaut euch wirklich euer Zeug an:
Was braucht ihr? Was braucht ihr nicht?
Ich weiß, wie es ist.
Man hat halt dann irgendwie noch so eine große Schüssel,
weil man sich denkt,
ja, und wenn dann mal wieder ein Geburtstag stattfindet,
brauche ich eine große Schüssel für viel Kartoffelsalat.
Dann habe ich aber vielleicht so einen kleinen Rest,
dann braucht man doch was Kleines.
Aber es ist doch schon häufig so, dass man oft zu viel hat.
Und was ich mittlerweile auch oft mache:
Wenn ich was abdecke oder verstaue
und zum Beispiel eine Emailleschüssel habe ohne Deckel,
dann mache ich halt einen Teller drauf.
Dann packt man es halt mit dem Teller in den Kühlschrank.
Und man braucht nicht für jedes Szenario
die perfekte Lösung.
Ich glaube, das muss man sich vielleicht eingestehen
und halt ausmisten.
Hat das gerade die Queen der Vorratsbehälter gesagt?
>> JOSH: Ja.
>> SALLY: Aber ich finde es für unsere Verhältnisse okay,
oder?
>> JOSH: Ja.
>> SALLY: Und jetzt kommt mein Lieblingsschrank.
Und ich glaube, auf den habt ihr alle gewartet.
Das ist nämlich mein Backschrank,
meine ganzen Backvorräte.
Wahrscheinlich bin ich der einzige Haushalt,
der so viele Backvorräte hat.
Ihr könnt in diesem Schrank alles verstauen,
Backvorräte, Kochvorräte, Flaschen, Getränke.
Im Prinzip würde einer auch ausreichen, finde ich,
für so einen ganz normalen Haushalt.
Das ist jetzt so ein Kesseböhmer.
Tandem heißt der, weil er nämlich...
Also ist es so, dass praktisch die Hälfte des Schrank-
– oder ein Drittel des Schrankinhalts hier drin ist
und die anderen zwei Drittel sind hier drin.
Und es ist wirklich besser, als wenn man einen Schrank hat,
der eben nur Einlegeböden hat.
Denn er halbiert sich
oder drittelt sich eben
und man hat hier eben ein Drittel
und da den Rest.
Man sieht alles übersichtlicher
und kann alles so verstauen,
dass man nichts mehr drin vergisst.
Und bei uns hier das ist sogar noch das alte Modell.
Da gibt es jetzt ein neueres, was ich besser finde.
Denn hier habe ich ja diese Kante,
wo einfach die Dosen nicht perfekt reinpassen.
Und beim neueren Modell hat man
hier wirklich einen rechten Winkel.
Also man gewinnt noch diese Ecke
und es verschiebt sich halt auch nichts.
Wir haben halt zwei Jahre zu früh gebaut.
Ich habe hier vorne, wie gesagt,
so durchsichtige Dosen, die alle gut verschließen.
Das heißt, die sind alle luftdicht verpackt.
Dann habe ich alle beschriftet
und habe hier einfach
hier
– und das war immer das Chaos, was bei uns entstanden ist.
Also die waren sowieso immer beschriftet.
Ich habe es jetzt nur einheitlich beschriftet.
Und wo immer Chaos entstanden ist,
war, wenn Vorräte leer sind und aufgebraucht sind,
wie jetzt zum Beispiel hier Schokodrops.
Die sind jetzt leer.
Dann ist vielleicht
hier oben Vanilleextrakt leer.
Dann ist vielleicht noch
die Raspelschokolade leer.
Und dann war es eben so:
Wenn ich hier Lücken habe
und die nicht beschriftet sind
und man beim nächsten Einkauf nicht drauf achtet,
stellt einer vielleicht die Raspelschokolade da rein,
das andere unten rein.
Und da ist eben immer Unordnung entstanden.
Das heißt, wenn ihr den Platz habt,
dann beschriftet eben den Platz an sich.
Jetzt weiß jeder, hier kommt die Raspelschokolade rein,
hier die Schokodrops
und da oben Vanilleextrakt.
Ich frage mich, warum ich nur noch zwei habe, aber gut.
Ein kleiner Vorrat.
Und was ihr hier im Prinzip bedenken müsst einfach
– so mache ich es.
Ich habe immer eine Reihe.
Und wenn ihr aber sagt:
"Ich habe nicht sechs Päckchen Kakao,
weil ich nicht so viel brauche",
dann könnt ihr ja trotzdem sinnvolle Lebensmittel
hintereinander lagern.
Denn auf euren Fotos habe ich gesehen,
dass ihr oft auch Schubladen habt.
Schubladen sind auch gut,
weil man eben von oben reinschaut
und von oben hat man den Vorteil,
man kann jedes Teil an sich gut erkennen.
Hier muss man natürlich nach hinten durch
immer schon ein bisschen mitdenken und sagen:
Was verstaue ich denn jetzt wo?
Und bei den Schubladen wäre es aber auch wichtig.
Gerade dieses eine Foto, was ich hier zeige,
da sind Lebensmittel drin in Schubladen
und ihr seht gar nicht, was es ist,
weil eben teilweise Sachen nicht beschriftet sind.
Falls ihr also Verpackungen habt
und was von oben sehen wollt,
dann schreibt einfach drauf, was es ist.
Und dann, finde ich, gibt es da auch kein Durcheinander.
Hier oben habe ich dann den kleinen Platz noch
genutzt für Küchenrolle und Taschentücher.
Und im Prinzip auch hier:
Alles, was ich häufiger brauche, ist auf Augenhöhe
und eben zwischen Knie- und Augenhöhe.
Und alles, was ich weniger benutze,
weiter oben oder weiter unten.
Das heißt, so Geliermittel wie Blatt-Vegatine
oder Backoblaten oder Schokolade auf Vorrat
habe ich eher unten
und alles andere, was ich häufig brauche, oben,
so wie zum Beispiel unsere Porridge-Zutaten.
Deswegen haben wir hier die Haferflocken,
hier oben direkt die Nüsse.
Das sind wirklich Dinge,
die einfach jeden Tag zum Einsatz kommen.
Schön, gell?
Ich liebe meinen Backschrank so sehr!
Ich liebe ihn einfach.
Hier habe ich noch weitere Bevorratung
und zwar Bevorratung Lebensmittel, aber auch
Küchenhelfer.
Ich habe hier zum Beispiel Gläser, die wir eigentlich
eigentlich, wenn wir ehrlich sind, nie brauchen.
Aber wir haben sie, weil wir zum Beispiel
das auch als Dessertgläser benutzen
für Eis oder für Nachtisch.
Und wir behalten sie halt auch, weil ich sagen muss,
dass wir halt oft, wenn wir auch Bücher machen
oder doch mal ein Rezept fotografieren
– wir brauchen es halt dann doch irgendwann.
Aber es ist da oben und da ist es okay.
Hier haben wir wieder auf Augenhöhe
einfach alle trockenen Lebensmittel, die ich häufig brauche.
Und die brauche ich wirklich oft,
so was wie Mehl, Zucker, Stärke,
Salz, Haferflocken,
brauner Zucker.
Und auch hier einfach das auf Vorrat haben,
was man wirklich auch oft benutzt.
Hier habe ich so ein kleines Fach
und da sind Pizzableche und Ofenbleche drin.
Und das Geschirr haben wir hier,
weil wir eben hier den Esstisch haben.
Das heißt, Geschirr haben wir da,
wo wir es eben auch brauchen,
hier und hier.
Und hier habe ich jetzt ein Fach für Backbleche,
weil ich die normalerweise da unten drin hatte
unterm Backofen.
Aber hier kann ich sie halt echt schön reinstapeln,
ohne dass sie ständig umfallen.
Das ist halt echt gut.
Wie gesagt, hier häufig genutzte Lebensmittel,
die Backbleche, die Backformen und das Geschirr.
Und hier unten habe ich dann noch Lebensmittelvorräte,
die ich auch immer mal wieder brauche,
so was wie Essig und Öl.
Hier habe ich noch Milch.
Gut, das ist jetzt der Vorrat ein bisschen leer.
Aber, wie gesagt, wenn er voll ist, ist hier alles immer drin.
Und weiter unten eben noch andere Lebensmittel,
die ich noch seltener brauche,
so was wie Konserven.
Und hier habe ich auch die Nudeln drin.
Die finde ich auch praktisch da unten drin,
weil ich eben von oben lesen kann, was es für Nudeln sind.
Bei den Konserven, muss ich sagen,
habe ich es auch hier mit dem SpaceFlexx gelöst,
weil ich dann Gruppierungen gemacht habe,
also so was wie Obst und Gemüse.
Und dann habe ich da vorne noch die Marmeladengläser.
Wenn ihr aber Platz habt hier in so einem Schrank,
ist es natürlich noch besser.
Denn da kann man von vorne lesen, was man drinnen hat.
Und hier habe ich einfach so die Kochvorräte,
die Brotbackmischungen,
auch so was wie Linsen, Reis und so weiter.
Und ich habe hier jetzt beim Ausmisten
einfach auch wieder Platz geschaffen.
Und das ist auch immer ganz gut.
Denn, wenn ihr alles praktisch ganz perfekt einräumt,
dass es so zu 100 Prozent voll ist,
dann passiert eben wieder das,
dass ihr was Neues habt, ein neues Lebensmittel,
irgendwie ihr macht eine besondere Torte
oder ein besonderes Gericht,
habt doch noch was übrig
und dann habt ihr keinen Platz dafür.
Das heißt, ich habe jetzt hier Platz
und unten und hier oben.
Und das lasse ich jetzt auch erst mal so.
Ja. Und dann habe ich im Prinzip hier meine Vorräte
eigentlich durch.
Und ich habe ja hier in der Küche auch
praktisch die Küche und den Vorratsraum in einem.
Das heißt, ich muss meine Vorräte, die ich habe,
und die angebrochenen Lebensmittel, die ich habe,
in einem Raum verstauen.
In unserer Küche drüben habe ich es ja so,
dass ich eine kleinere Küche habe
– auch groß genug, aber klein –
und nebendran ist der Hauswirtschaftsraum, der Vorratsraum,
und da sind praktisch alle Vorräte drin.
Und deswegen habe ich dort
weniger Schränke und Schubladen in der Küche,
aber sozusagen dann den Vorrat im Vorratsraum.
Und jetzt bleibt im Prinzip nur noch die eine Kategorie übrig
und zwar ist das die Aufbewahrung von diversen Dingen,
die man in der Küche nicht jeden Tag braucht,
so was wie Vorratsgläser,
so was wie auch meine Modelliersachen,
die Cake
– also Tortenzubehör.
Das zeige ich euch kurz da.
[Musik]
Ja, wie gesagt, die Rückseite der Insel,
da bin ich echt nicht so häufig.
Und da sind eben die Dinge,
die ich nicht so häufig auch brauche,
wie zum Beispiel meine Glasvorräte, die Flaschen,
aber auch Cake Boards,
Cake Dummys und so weiter,
die Ganaching Boards, die ich einfach nicht brauche,
die aber immer wieder, wenn sie übereinander liegen,
durcheinander sind.
Da habe ich jetzt auch den SpaceFlexx,
muss ich sagen, eingebaut,
weil sie so einfach alle aufrecht stehen
und ich sie von oben eben auch rausnehmen kann,
ohne dass die Sachen
– oh! –
ohne dass die Sachen eben durcheinanderkommen.
Und hier muss ich zu meiner Verteidigung sagen,
ich habe echt viele Gläser und viele Vorratsbehälter,
gerade was Marmeladen und Flaschen angeht,
aber ich koche halt auch viel Marmelade ein.
Also immer wenn wir hier Obst übrig haben
und gerade im Sommer koche ich viel ein,
brauche vor allem deswegen
ganz viele verschieden große Vorratsgläser.
Und die habe ich jetzt alle hier vorne,
weil ich sie halt echt nicht täglich brauche.
Aber irgendwo muss man es eben verstauen.
Und in unserer alten Wohnung hatte ich sie teilweise
im Keller in so Kisten und Körbchen drin.
Und hier habe ich einfach auf der Rückseite der Insel
echt den Platz.
Vasen sind hier unten, weil auch
– und auch Karaffen,
weil wir die auch dann am Tisch brauchen
und dann kann man sie hier rausholen,
kurz mit Wasser befüllen und fertig.
Und im Prinzip habe ich hier dann noch
einfach eine Schublade mit diversen Dingen zum Anrichten
für unsere Sets vorne für die Fotos.
Und hier haben wir mit dem Josh eine kleine Büroschublade,
wo ich zum Beispiel
– wo wir die Klappe drin haben,
das Etikettiergerät, dass ich da immer drankomme,
unsere Mikrofone für unsere Karaoke-Einheiten,
ja, und Stifte, Autogrammkarten,
weil das so Dinge sind, die wir hier brauchen.
Und wenn uns der Hunger packt,
haben wir hier auch immer Nougatschnitten.
Es ist schon sehr spät am Abend
und ich würde gern alle Nougatschnitten aufessen.
Aber ich tu es nicht.
Denn ich bin stark.
Wow!
Ich muss sagen, dass ich gerade sehr
kaputt bin.
Denn wir haben jetzt vier Tage lang die Küche umorganisiert.
Gut, das Etikettieren hat mich sehr glücklich gemacht
zwischendurch, muss ich sagen.
Und das macht mich jetzt nicht so kaputt.
Aber es ist doch schon ziemlich schwer,
vor allem so eine große Küche ordentlich zu halten.
Denn in großen Räumen sammelt sich viel an.
Ich weiß noch, Murats alter Chef hat immer gesagt,
dass
– also er hat mal im kompletten Geschäft
alle Tische wegschmeißen lassen.
Und dann hat der Murat gesagt:
"Warum machst du das denn?"
Und dann hat er gesagt: "Ja, aus einem einfachen Grund:
Überall, wo eine Ablage steht, wird was vollgestellt."
Und genau so sehe ich das auch.
Das heißt, hat man zu viel Stauraum, stellt man alles voll,
hat man zu wenig, steht alles voll.
Also man muss so ein gesundes Mittelmaß finden.
Und bei mir ist es halt echt so, ich bin so ein Aufräumfreak.
Ich stehe dazu.
Ich bin so ein kleiner Monk, der alles ordentlich haben will.
Aber würde ich das nicht machen
und würde ich das nicht sein,
würde halt so ein Haus ganz schnell mal zugestellt werden.
Und ich glaube, das kann jeder bestätigen,
der in einem Haus wohnt.
Deswegen bin ich da immer hinterher,
dass ich eben alles sofort aufräume,
alles etikettiere, alles seinen Platz hat.
Und ja, gerade hier in der Küche,
ich muss sagen, 100 Prozent bin ich noch nicht ganz zufrieden,
gerade hier vorne.
Ich habe ja auch unseren ganzen Fondant,
die Deko, die Streusel.
Ihr habt gesehen, ich meine Streusel da rausgeräumt,
weil ich weiß, ich benutze meine Streusel nicht jeden Tag.
Und ich denke, dass ich euch mit diesem Video
schon ein paar Tipps und Tricks geben konnte,
wie ihr eure Küche und euren Haushalt ordentlich halten könnt,
wie ihr einfach ein bisschen Struktur schaffen könnt,
was ihr braucht, was ihr vielleicht nicht braucht
und vor allem wie ihr diese Küchenzonen einteilen könnt.
Und mein großer Wunsch wäre es ja,
dass ich mal zu euch nach Hause komme, in euren Haushalt
und euren Haushalt organisiere.
So ein bisschen haben wir es ja gemacht
mit den Fotos, die ihr mir geschickt habt.
Ich hoffe, ich konnte euch da ein bisschen Feedback,
ein bisschen Rückmeldung und Hilfestellung geben.
Ich denke schon.
Ich weiß, man kann alles noch tausendmal besser machen
und umorganisieren.
Irgendwo muss man halt doch schon einen Punkt machen
und sagen, okay, so lasse ich es jetzt erst mal.
Wie gesagt, bei mir hier vorne
so mit Fondant- und Streuselschublade
und Motivtortenzubehör
muss ich selbst auch noch ein bisschen gucken.
Wer weiß, vielleicht gibt es nächstes Jahr
oder in einem halben Jahr einfach noch mal ein Update,
wenn ich komplett fertig bin.
Aber es ist halt auch sehr, sehr schwierig für mich,
hier die Ordnung reinzubringen,
zumal ich ja jetzt nicht gerade nichts zu tun habe.
Das heißt, wir drehen ja hier Videos, machen Fotos und alles.
Und das alles nebenher zu organisieren, ist schon schwierig.
Aber jetzt sind wir alle im Team, glaube ich,
recht gut mit dabei.
Alle haben hier mitgeholfen,
zumindest ein Teil davon.
Und dadurch, dass jetzt alles recht etikettiert ist,
muss ich sagen, hoffe ich,
dass die Ordnung jetzt erst mal so bleibt.
Falls ihr noch Fragen habt, Anregungen, Wünsche, Ideen,
dann schreibt sie einfach in die Kommentare.
Ich hoffe, euch hat das Video ein bisschen Spaß gemacht
und wir sehen uns wieder beim nächsten Mal.
Tschüss!
Ich gucke mir jetzt noch mal meinen Backschrank an.
Dann bin ich happy.
Und dann verlasse ich die Küche für heute.
Ja.
[Musik]
Hach! Er ist so schön!
Oh!
[Musik]
Ich freue mich, wenn ich hier morgen
wieder Porridge machen kann.
[Musik]
Ich bin so happy!